it's my great pleasure to introduce unc
chen from duke
uh so if you don't know unc achieved
instant uh mathematical stardom last
year by making a spectacular improvement
on the status of the kls conjecture
and today is also going to make a
spectacular improvement but on our work
i guess all right it's going to talk
about mala and mixing time of mahala
thank you philip for the nice
introduction and first of all i would
like to thank
organizers for putting up this wonderful
workshop with a mix
of like varied people with very diverse
background
today i'm going to talk about mixing
mini max mixing time format of mala for
low concave sampling
this is joint work with uh with kuru
and scott schmidler karlou is a phd
student
co-advised by me and scott and scott is
colleague in
our department of statical science the
paper is posted
on archive
okay
so
the top will be three part
first i just set up the
the minimax setting i have to define
what's in the mean and what's in the max
and then the second section will be uh
to
to design like to find a hard target
distribution and describe how do we
establish the lower bond and then the
last part will explain how do we improve
the current uh mixing timeout run for
formula
okay let's get into the setting so the
setting has been come up multiple times
in this workshop we're trying to sample
from a lot concave target distribution
so
e to the minus f where f is convex
and i'll specify additional assumptions
later and we focus on one type of
algorithm just uh metropolis suggested
language algorithm uh this has also been
described so it starts with some initial
distribution and iteratively uh
it draws samples from a proposal
distribution that is just like you take
a gradient step and then add some noise
and the scale of the noise is
is basically square root of this step
size h
and uh
and then you use the
hastings step to do accept reject and
this is basically um
uh to to ensure that this uh mala
algorithm uh converges to the correct
target distribution okay so if you don't
have this metropolis thing then you have
uh
unadjusted on german and you have some
asymptotically your samples will be
biased um
okay so
the the mixing time
is simple so it uh if we denote the t to
denote the transition operator of the
markov chain
uh the mu n is the distribution at
iteration n then the mixing time is the
first time
uh when the total variational distance
between the mu and the target and the
target distribution is less than epsilon
okay
um
and then we we try to understand this uh
minimax making time in in this sense
so
look at this quantity so here we have
the total variational mixing time here
as a function of epsilon and initial
distribution so we fix all these
parameters dimension d
um
uh the smoothness parameter l and
strongly log concave parameter m and
epsilon n
and then the nature will choose
uh a warm star uh i won't start defined
in this sense that
the ratio between
the initial distribution target
distribution is bounded by m
and nature will choose one star
and then nature will choose the target
distribution the target's distribution
will be lower concave distributions
there are block smooth so the hessian of
the f is bonded by l
and strongly law concave the hessian is
lower bounded by small small m
and it lives in d dimensional space
and what you can do as
someone running the algorithm you can
choose the step size h in mala okay is
this
minimax setting clear
and in the following we'll try to make
some simplifications that that is still
kind of hard problem what we'll do is i
will focus on the dimension d and the
condition number khabar dependency
so here
i forgot to mention that the cover here
is the condition number is basically
uh l over
m
okay and we will focus on
to discuss this minimax mixing time
we'll focus on d and kabba and we're
gonna
all poly logarithmic dependency on d
kappa and one over epsilon
um
and we assume that basically log m
the the warmness
is only log logarithmic dependency on d
and n kappa and so in our setting where
we ignore all this logo polylog
dependency
this warmness is treated as a constant
and it is referred as one star in the
following okay
so what is our goal we try to prove a
tight
upper and lower bond for
mini max mixing time in this sense so if
we fix this to be a warm start m
and we want to prove this mini max
mixing time ignoring all this polylog
dependency on d kappa and one over
epsilon this is roughly kappa e to the
one half
okay that says that actually for
for for this class of problem
if nature is allowed to choose this uh
log concave distribution strongly law
concave smooth
uh
you have to pay like if you apply malala
you have to pay some dimension
dependency of d1 half and have to pay
the conditional dependency condition
number dependency kappa
okay
um
so of course we're not the only one
working on this airplane lower bound
formula so the early works those dates
back to
robots and rosento says here talking
about some like
uh
old work where i tried there they tried
to do work out this uh
what's the correct step size for mala
and they find that asymptotically d to
the minus one third was the correct step
size scaling for
productive solutions with some high
order regularities
and there are also many other settings
uh for the in the time of in the limited
time i will not be able to talk about
them but yeah there are settings people
assume like very high order derivatives
try to work out the discretization error
and like especially in those bulrabbi
heavenly and hair flavors
and
then in this course we'll focus on
exactly our setting exactly this
l log smooth and m strongly log concave
setting and in this case uh we'll list
some of the
very recent work
and the first was the dvd and all
2019
they proved
under basically under warm star
the mixing time upper bound is
of this form so you have a max of two
quantities e to the one half kabat to
the two thirds
uh
tabata three half and d to the
d times kappa the max of these two
quantities so it's kind of
slightly larger than ours but it's very
close and then uh
in uh in our paper in 2020 we actually
uh
improve the warmness dependency a little
bit we will try to be able to prove that
even if you initialize
from this gaussian distribution and you
will get similar mixing time upper bound
and then
in 2020 and leonard paper
they proved that from
a
gaussian star with uh variance one over
l identity
uh you will put you have a mixing time
of uh
kaba times d which is uh taking
basically the second term here
and
then in the you know on tuesday we have
seen that uh sinho
uh and and and all the and phillip and
all they have shown uh mixing time upper
bound
from one star which is uh d to the one
half kabat to the three half
it's actually taking the the second to
the first term here so it's also better
uh
and in our paper in our paper we try to
prove so d to the one half and kappa
here as an upper bound from
warm star
and it's worth noting that actually
you can say that in this paper they
already achieved
uh
e to the one half kaba by combining the
the the tuesday talk by singhol and uh
the the wednesday talk by rochi uh
there's a
reduction framework that allows you to
shave off all the kabbal dependency but
then you have to use that algorithm that
which is not
right we have so if we focus on mala
this will be the
the current story okay
any questions about this
and there are also previous work on uh
on the lower bound the lower bound
problem
consists of finding uh harder target
distributions where mala have difficulty
to sample from
and actually for
for this like specific kind of
constructions very very concrete
constructions actually started in
uh two you know 20
uh
they were trying to they pro they
constructed a target distribution with a
perturbed version of gaussian which is
easy to analyze but very hard for them
to to sample for for
for
formula and they prove they prove a
spectral upper bond special gap have
uh of order d to the one half which
usually like a spectral gap
upper bound implies the mixing time
directly but in the continuous time
uh markov continuous state markov chains
it's not that trivial so
we we have we will present some work
trying to
make this link but actually essentially
they proved this dimension dependency
should be e to the one half
and
so if we don't assume warm star very
like cons like
one star is our father log poly log b
uh
a log of
warmness is polylog b
then uh it's hard to get it's hard to
get b to the one half dependency in this
paper uh 2011 paper they show that
actually kevin presented on tuesday they
show that if you have uh initialization
that is
exponential to the d1
then uh
to get
my last two mix you have to take a d
times kappa so you cannot get e to the
one half okay it's only possible to get
b to the one half
when you assume a worm star okay
um
quick quick comment uh i think kevin
pointed out to me that uh for our lower
bound like we construct a
set s of like
a pretty high probability such that like
the conductance out of this set is is uh
exponentially small if the step size is
taken too too large so uh if you like
take
as your um
your initialization the distribution
which which like starts in this bad set
then
it seems like it would imply a mixing
time lower bound under warm start
maybe maybe we could discuss this
afterwards but yeah thanks thanks for
the comment yeah we'll discuss offline
okay
yeah well sorry so these are lower
bounds just for mala yes just for mala
yeah so why is that interesting i mean
uh it's interesting mostly for
theoretical purpose like for people
studying mala
uh you know that you can not prove to
better rate so you will not be able to
but i mean like you saw in the previous
talk there are 10 different very
interesting algorithms right i agree i
totally agree
i think this lower bond yeah does not
hold for other algorithms for hmc for
example already doesn't hold yeah do you
expect it holds if you restrict to
gradients only gradient computations
only
yeah it's hard to say it's some one of
the conjectures like uh zing hall was
trying to impose an open problem session
but it's difficult to get so we we only
get be able to get very like specific to
mala and these are the kind of the lower
bonds okay
thanks
okay let's first talk about the lower
bond which is uh
has a lot of tedious calculation but in
presentation it might be easier so yeah
so the lower bound sketch here is is uh
it's
it's very
is used in many places so
we just consider one algorithm so it's
not that hard to establish lower bonds
so we first find a hard target
distribution and then we try to prove
its special gap is small and then we try
to get a mixing time lower bond from
spectral gap upper one
okay
the first part is
is is largely inspired by previous
worker uh leonard and chewie this
construction they basically in liao 20
they got for gaussian distribution they
got the kabbalah dependency tight and
true in all they got the dimension
dependency type and
yeah so we were at at that time like
when single published their paper or
like posted paper on archive we're
working on some similar problems but
uh
a similar kind of construction but we
find that their construction is actually
much better than ours it's easier to
analyze so it's we can adopt this kind
of construction so
if you look at this construction of f so
the target distribution will be e to the
minus f right uh
this construction of f has kind of two
type
of components you basically
has the gaussian part of the quadratic
part and you have a third part is like
this cosine functions
and what's the intuition here
is like for the first d minus one
dimension you have a perturbed
gaussian part and y is this type of
perturbation you can try to take the
second derivative of this quantity
the second derivative and look at
testing you you will see that the
hessian actually oscillates between uh
one half one half one over two l and
three over two l i always smoothness
parameter
and oscillation is very fast because the
the it's like d is inside this bracket
uh when you take second derivative will
be like some constant minus some cosine
d to the one fourth x and this
oscillation very fast basically
well uh
will make the make the
uh
like you you have to take a large
you have to take a small step size in
mala to be able to
to achieve a small
accept reject rate and this will give
you the the correct dimension dependency
and and yeah the construction and
chewing always very kind of smart and i
recommend take a look at this and
and then you look at this last dimension
you just need actually one dimension
that is
not does not have the same scaling than
the other dimensions this make up here
this small m and
this part makes the which is much
smaller than the the l and this
difference is enough to make up here the
kaba dependency in the mixing rate
can i ask
why is it one over root d in front of
the perturbation term
uh yeah so that's a good question so we
want the oscillation to be fast here in
the cosine term so we want to put some d
here and then at the same time you need
to ensure it is not concave so when you
take second derivative
this term is always positive so you have
a constant term one or further one
minus
the derivative second derivative you
will have like d to the
one force coming out two times and this
b dimension depending canceling out
cancel out will be like constant minus
cosine
and this is basically to make sure that
it's roughly constant maximus cosine
otherwise
yeah
so
gaussian is essentially to introduce
some oscillations of the
gradient
oscillation of the hessian yeah that
will also imply the oscillation of
gradient but it's uh
yeah because of this kind of scaling
it's interesting that you see that if
if all the x's actually concentrate
around square root d radius this does
not have much effect actually because
it's quite small but the when x is like
inside
this square of d radius
this starts to have like large effects
yeah so the second step is trying to
bounce get spectral gap of this this
target distribution i will not present
it here in the in the limit of time
it's feasible because so like we know
it's feasible but it's just tedious math
because it's a product distribution it's
a perturbed version of gaussian and you
can have all the derivative of this
function explicit
so then the third step is trying to get
mixing time from spectral gap
this is well known in actually in finite
space sampling
and for example you can take a look at
this
very well very well written review in
montenegro and italy 2006 uh
so somehow for the continuous space
mixing i don't know if people like maybe
people
like don't care about this kind of rate
we cannot find an explicit theorem that
relates the
the mixing time and spectral gap but we
have to dig a little bit into literature
that there exists the tools so this
theorem is not
hard to prove that we dig into
literature and find the correct theorems
then we prove something like the mixing
time is lower bounded by spectral gap of
some initialization mu zero and because
of this inequality you can construct
your mu zero find your spectral cap and
you get a lower bound for mixing time
okay
yeah so if you we cannot find that if
this is theorem like this for general
state space or continuously straight
markov chains if you know
something in the audience please let us
know
okay let's uh get into
the upper bound
um the upper bound is improved is
interesting there
there have been many attempts and
i'll try to show you like the refinement
in our proof but before that let's go
through the general like proof sketch
that
has appeared multiple times so so we use
conductance-based mixing time proof
this is not the only way to prove mixing
time but it's the way that
we use and it works well at least i know
very well this true technique
so this was first developed very well in
the finance-based market chains
and it actually became very popular
things uh uh lobas and simone knowledge
97 93 paper they made this serum
a
series of lemma that made this cons this
this type of proof very easy for
continuous space safe macro chains
and the typical strategy is like three
three steps
so you first show that
the contactants will give you a mixing
time
and then
to get a conductance which is the notion
that it's very difficult that you have
to control
uh all the quantity over all subsets
there's the way
like
is it sufficient
to to con to consider some kind of local
properties with what we call transition
overlap to get conductance i'll explain
this in details
and then the third step to to get this
local property is a transition overlap
or use some
it's sufficient to show the proposal
overlap and some
control of the accept reject rate
um
don't worry if you don't get this but i
explain this
so the first step uh
is to relate the conductance and the
mixing time
and the conductance is this quantity so
you have a transition kernel at
point x
and you look at the mass how much mass
you can transfer from uh
one subset a to its complement so the
picture
uh to draw is is like this
you have a set you have some
distribution and then you have a subset
a and a complement
and you try to look at how much mass you
can
transport from one side to the other
of course yeah
yeah if your like distribution behaves
well you expect this quantity to be
large
and if distribution have some kind of
bottleneck
then it's hard to transport marks from
this a and a complement here and then
your conductance will be slow and then
your mixing will be small
and your mixing time will be
will be
will be like large
okay
and so this um
lobaz and simon novich 1993 paper
show that this conductance lower
boundary implies mixing upper bound
the the total variational mixing time is
roughly one over
five square this is under one star and
we ignore all the other log factors
okay
and
there's some kind of improvement of
improvement of this technique
in their paper that in some cases
you really don't want to bond
the the mass kind of transfer for
certain very small
measure sets
and this s conductance serves this first
purpose that you don't actually need to
consider
all subsets a
with very small masses and you can
ignore them and define this as
conductance as conductance
also gives you a mixing up or down upper
bound as long as you choose this to be
not too large
okay
and the second step is also kind of
interesting uh proof technique and uh
overlap is because this conductance or s
conductance is something
seems like very difficult to bond you
have to go through
all the subsets a
like from size
s to one half and
like for convex style you have many many
ways to draw these subsets right so
directly bonding this quantity is
difficult and in this slow last 99 paper
they tried to say that oh
you don't need to
bond this conductance like
from its definition there's a way
to do bounded through local calculations
local calculation mean that
you just need to consider any two points
that is
some radius r apart and as long as you
can prove this
if there are radius are apart
their overlap the total variation
distance between their transition
distributions have a large overlap then
you get a mixing time you get a
conductance lower bond
um so it's like you have any point
x and y
and the proposal distribution might be
some kind of gaussian shape
around them
uh and then as long as you see it can
prove that if x for any two point x y
they are close in distance r
uh their overlap between
the gaussian proposals their
this overlap is large tv distance is
small
and then you can prove a
conductance lower bound like this
and what happened on the right side side
you have the idle temperature
coefficient
and
the radius r so
i think like uh centos just explained to
us as well it's this kind of
uh
genius kind of proof
proof strategy that you want to prove
something about markov chain but
you end up using the isoparametric
coefficient which is the intrinsic
probability of the density you want to
sample from okay
and for strongly low concave densities
this is
of order square root of n
and
the similar lemma holds for the s
conductance will not describe it uh that
gives some convenience because you
uh you don't need
you don't need to sorry here's
the typo
you need don't need to consider all x
and y you just need to consider x y in
some high probability set
um so because we use this type of
strategy our upper bound prove actually
it does not
does not need this strongly low concave
assumption necessary as long as it is
now concave and smooth and have some
kind of ado parametric coefficient
uh we will prove upper bound for mala
and uh you hot yeah usually
yeah you can get either parametric
coefficient without this strongly low
concave setting for example if you know
the target density have some bounded
variance and then you can get make use
of the
theorems related to the chaos conjecture
to get a isoparametric coefficient okay
so the last step
is trying to bond this uh total
variation the distance so this
transition this what we call transition
overlap so it's the tv distance between
this transition distribution at x and
at y
and the typical way it works is to
use the triangular inequality because
we know this
qx is a proposal distribution the
proposal distribution is regardless of
gaussian distribution so we know this
proposal distribution much better than
this transition distribution and make
use the
triangular inequality allow us to
isolate this proposal overlap and then
everything boils down to control this
accept reject rate here
okay
so yeah so this middle step
is easy because we use pink square
inequality and chao divergence between
gaussian is easy
and we have this
accept reject rate to control and let's
look at this excel project right here
we need to bond this
total variational distance between the
transition distribution and proposal
distribution for any x that is sampled
from target distribution with high
probability so this quantity
will be like one minus expected accept
reject rate so you basically have like
two type of randomness one is like you
only need one this quantity for x from
target with high volatility the other is
you have expectation over y which is
like the noise distribution when you
generate a proposal okay you won't bond
this term in
in high probability
and so you want to control this uh this
object accept reject rate uh in mala
um there have been many attempts
especially uh
with uh with russ dvd and
what we did in the phd like we tried to
bond this term
because like we thought this this is
kind of easy to bond and just use some
kind of taylor expansion and triangular
inequalities
uh
we not be able to get remember we get we
only get like t to the
uh
so max of two quantities like d carbon
and d to the two third kappa
uh
so roughly yeah roughly
it's not the the best rate we get but uh
so here the the takeaway here that if if
you
don't make use of these two kind of
randomness randomness in y and
randomness and x very well you will not
get a very good accepts rejecter control
um
and also so leonardo 20 paper
they already have a better use of the
randomness on on x
because if you know x is coming from log
concave distribution you have a better
way to bound the gradient of uh
something that is drawn from raw concave
distribution that's what they call the
the better gradient concentration for
log concave distributions and there they
improve yeah instead of our like max of
two quantities they get like just d
coupon which is better than ours
and
uh
thing all three and all they they take a
different approach instead of
considering this uh just looking at this
triangle inequality they said oh people
know the longevin division much better
than this discretize
this this molar and let's explore some
properties of longevity fusion to
to to to get a better estimate of this
accept project
right okay and we are kind of
an old school trying to bond this
quantity so this tiny day according to
three and all proof
has to be bonded very yeah very good but
yeah let's try to expand these terms and
see like
really what what are terms we cannot
bond and what the terms we can bond and
to see like what's the difficulty
so
so we have to make one connection to
bond this accept reject rate to see this
mala as a hamiltonian monte carlo with
uh one step of least freak leapfrog
integrator so let's this has been
introduced many times let's go through
it quickly you have this hamiltonian
function
this is the fq plus
square one over 2 p square
and
then from
the continuous dynamics
just satisfy this
two differential equations and then if
you discretize this this differential
equation you get
what we call
uh
hamiltonian
monte carlo the discretized version and
if you disprotest it with a leapfrog
integrator then you get this type of
updates and
the updates for q if you stare at it
it
will look very looks look very similar
to the mala update
so the update on q will be
q0 plus eta p 0 minus eta squared over 2
gradient of
f q 0 so if you think this you identify
this q 0 is the initial state x
p 0 is a noise you add when you propose
and this is exactly
x minus
some gradient term plus some noise term
and
the step size exactly match if you think
h is eta square over two okay
so this is a connection and this
actually makes our own analysis easier
because
now we can also make use of this
a lot of things proved for hamiltonian
monte carlo so the mala accept reject
rate
in the pq notation
it just becomes
this
remember the in the x y notation is this
but from this to the pq notation is just
the transform of those variables nothing
else
and then we make use that the continuous
hamidonium on piccolo dynamics conserves
the hamiltonian
so the attendant anytime t
f q t plus the one half p t square is
equal to f q zero plus one half p zero
squared and then we can replace
basically replace this term
replace this term with this term
so after replacing this term
we get this term right so at time so
this will be the continuous dynamic at
time eta this will be the leapfrog
integration of this hamiltonian dynamic
time eta so the mala accept reject rate
is just running
hmc for one step with the leapfrog
integrator and look at the discrete
addition error on the hamiltonian so
everything boys want to control
this
hmc discrete edition error
so we
let's say how we bonded this uh this
discretization error on the hamiltonian
this is our kind of key lemma which is
uh new in in our proof
you can try to bond this quantity like
by
uh
by like triangular inequalities and
there are some terms left and we ended
up bonding this like this and
the the second part
is basically
from triangle inequalities and gradient
concentration and the first part is our
kind of new part and from here you can
see the
the to make this accept reject rate to
be about
constant order
then the step size eta square will be
take 1 over square root d and h is of
order of theta so
h is of order of theta one over square d
and
i forgot to explain the conductance will
be just roughly one over m h
and
the mixing time will be
time be one over c square then it's
roughly
sorry one over squared
uh
sorry sir
yeah
oh yeah the mixing time i think yeah
sorry
i did too fast but yeah so mixing time
let's quick quickly go through this
so you have the isofamily coefficient
phi square root of m this
r will be of all the square root of h
okay
so the conductance will be square root
of h square root of m
sorry
and mixing one over c squared m times h
no
one know one over mh right so it's
roughly
half r times d to the one half okay this
is a calculation so you need to make up
here like basically the discretization
error that has like either add that to
the first d or added to the one half d
half and if you just use triangle and
quality things like that this term will
not be bonded uh with this order of of
the dependency
and the interesting thing that i want to
show it it's kind of complicated
if after you have done all these
triangular inequalities and gradient
concentration the term that is kind of
magically left is this type of term what
we call be it here
it's interesting it's a complicated term
but it's an interesting term that
that can like magically you can bound
this term in high probability what does
this roughly means it's like you have
this gradient of f at
q at s this is roughly
p at s roughly some discretization of p
of s
and you have the term at this 2n at time
0 and the time at time eta
this is the
t equals zero t equals to eta and then
you want to bond this upper bound this
term it looks like you can bond this
term using some kind of convexity
argument you have term only to end and
things in the middle actually this proof
does not use any of these convexity
arguments and
is simply based on some kind of
change of a lot of change of variables a
gradient concentration and herbs
argument i will not go through this
okay so
uh
that that that we are with this through
we will be able to prove this due to the
one-half cupboard kind of dependence
mixing hand combat dependency so we also
did some mixing time
uh like simulations so we consider the
hard distribution uh that appeared in
the lower bound proof and then we try to
you choose the step size with different
d to the gamma exponent
and
from we also tried like two one like
either one star or exponential d star
that appeared in a tiana lionel paper
that uh kevin presented on tuesday and
see actually what's the right gamma
actually leads to the correct accept
reject rate all the correct kind of
mixing time and the mixing time we don't
have the exact handle we have to use
some kind of proxy that is the hitting
time when the error the in in quantile
90 quantile is small okay
and let's look at this plot
for the top top left claw
first
uh here we show the accept reject rate
as a function of dimension
uh when you increase the dimension and
you change the
you change the gamma parameter
and what you expect is the
uh
when this uh gamma is about 0.5 is shown
in this solid line this should achieve
some kind of constant accept reject rate
that's what we our proof trying to
establish
and if you choose a two large step size
your accept reject rate should decrease
to zero if you choose a two smaller step
size uh
two small step size then accept reject
rate will will go to one okay so you
want to keep that step reject about
constant
and also keep the large step size
because you
that those kind of both matters for your
mixing time
and you can show that if you choose the
gamma that is different to 0.5 it goes
down it it's interesting that in
simulation this it goes down very slowly
and we were at like 10 to the seven and
it's near still not
at zero yet so it's kind of interesting
in practice you might be able to show
that you might be able to use the
slightly larger step size uh unless your
dimension is of order 10 to the 7 or
something and on the right plot we show
the mixing time you can show you can
that the like epox the proxy for making
time as a function dimension the proxy
for mixing time you can see that the
solid line with the gamma equals
0.5 uh
exponent has the lowest kind of mixing
time uh epoxy mixing time
uh we show something for uh the similar
things for
for for bad star where the best are
appeared in this uh
kevin's talk and you can see that for
bed star you really need to take
gamma e to the d to the minus one half
like small step size otherwise your step
your step reject will drop very fast to
zero okay and that's this kind of
kind of different situation so it's hard
it's hard to get b to the one half
dependency if you really have a bad
start
okay let's summarize so we established
the mini max mixing time for mala for
long concave sampling from a warm start
which is due to the one half kaba
for people like trying to implement so
we can really try to give some kind of
interesting advice that if you have
moderate dimension it's very small then
you really don't care about the
dimension dependency you can you might
be able to choose a step as one over l
like people choose for optimization but
if you really consider this law concave
sampling
and
you don't know much other than it's just
not concave and dimension is large you
should choose one over d to the one half
step size
uh it is might be okay like in this
robots and rosetta paper it might be a
way to choose the larger steps that if
you believe the target distribution is
like gaussian-like and has high order
regularities
but if your initialization is really bad
like kevin showed that you need to
choose a very small step size one
already for mala
okay and
some open directions some of them
already appear yesterday
that you want to remove the requirement
of warm stuff you want to have adapt
step choice for malar and you want to
also show something similar for
hamiltonian monte carlo and that's the
end of my talk thank you
questions
uh maybe i'll ask one
so it's kind of interesting that you
actually compared the mala with hmc
discrimination so i guess naturally one
would
be curious about what if you do a uh
metropolis adjusted under that long-term
sampling
you thought about that
that's an interesting question i
i'm not an expert on this but i heard
that if you just use the hmc on uh
pacing adjustment for under them you
don't get as good as the dimension
dependency for mixing
when you compare it to the undigested
version but i'm not very sure
thanks
other questions
uh can you extend this result to k-step
hmc yeah that's that's what we were
trying to do and we can discuss after
this yeah it's not easy so somehow i i
don't i think we lack some understanding
of this quantity and i uh yeah there are
there are experts on hamilton dynamics
and continuous dynamics here in the in
audience
i would be happy to discuss if you can
tell me what's actually the meaning of
this type of quantity why does it
magically is actually very small uh
discretization error for this type of
quantities and that will help also for
understanding like for hamiltonian monte
carlo why uh
why uh why can we other why can the
current proof cannot get a good accept
reject rate and how to improve
uh in your open directions uh you
mentioned like
developing new proof techniques beyond s
conductance in light of your lower bound
um what what what exactly like do you
hope to accomplish with this bullet
point
yeah i don't know that currently we're
kind of stuck at this kind of s
conductance proof but if you look at
discrete sampling literature you have
all these kind of kind of proofs that
does not based on the conductance and
they get better dependency on the
warmness and we're looking at it and
currently we don't know about this kind
of one one thing we we are learning
still yeah can you rule out uh
logs of love and equality
sorry it's basically for the warmness
dependence it's not the log sublime
quality you have a log log and kind of
dependency yeah
for strongly low concave you
distributions yeah
right so the s conductance forces you to
use a warm start yeah so you only have
to get log m dependency if you use the s
conducting
argument in our proof yes if you had a
log symbol of inequality you could hope
for a log log yes but we kind of
expected that even if you don't
explicitly assume that logs of
inequality
deal with the strongly log concave
distributions you should also get log
log m that's somehow in a lot of
simulations we do we don't really see
this warmness dependency and that's kind
of intriguing yeah
uh if someone can construct also lower
bound cases like worst case examples
where you have to pay this warmness
dependency that is also interesting yeah
doesn't your lower bound for instance
like rule out the possibility of of
getting this log log m dependence
yeah yeah so yeah but we don't know if
there are low bonds like that right
so like uh do you mean like
like developing proof techniques that uh
use the initialization beyond just the
warmness parameter because that seems
like the only way to really get get
around your lower bound develop
techniques where only has log log m kind
of dependency yeah but like if the only
thing that your proof uses is the
warmness and initialization
then your lower bound would
sorry like uh
like the lower bound i guess like i'm
talking about kevin's lower bound here
like
that that would rule out the possibility
of log log m dependence with d to the
one half
right
uh i'm not sure but yeah i have to think
about it yeah let's discuss after yeah
all right so uh since it's uh time for
legends i suggest we all thank uh unc
and all the speakers of this morning
and we'll meet again at two enjoy your
lunch
[Music]